you do that to me and I'll knock you
sleep in the air huh no you should find
out that for you oversold the flight I
can't let's see I paid for that it's
called the air rage and it seems to be
happening more frequently arguments and
fights turn into violent anger which is
often directed at the in-flight crew but
is the crew part of the problem or are
they simply left holding the bag Derrick
Thompson is senior editor for the
Atlantic and recently wrote about the
uptick in confrontations Derrick good
morning good morning you say in your
article that flight attendants are set
up to fail what do you mean I think the
airlines are squeezing both the
passengers and the employees sometimes
literally these the width of seats yes
that's decline by five to ten percent
since 1980s the pitch which is
essentially the officious term for
legroom is declined by three to five
inches in the same time so you're you're
squeezing people in coach well at the
same time that there are fewer crew
members per plane sometimes they have
cut their pensions stagnated their pay
and as a result you have the situation
where people are packed onto planes they
are there to be frustrated right
something is set to be lit and when
something happens that's wrong you can't
scream at the person or at the contract
of carriage you can't scream at the
executive board
you can only scream at those employees
but you also were saying to us that
we're seeing numbers go down in
cancellations and people being bumped
off flights so why are we seeing more of
these incidents now this is what's so
fascinating about what's happening right
now in the airlines because on the one
hand there's this sense of a weekly
program a new viral video every seven
days on United then on American and then
on Southwest with the fights but the
Department of Transportation data tells
an entirely different story the number
of cancellations is down people bumped
from flights is down complaints are down
and so what appears to be happening is
this actual incidences of negative
behavior terrible behavior their
frequency is going down but their
publicity is going up so it's creating
this perception that the instances are
going out on this in these cases the
face it you have some particularly
outrageous incidents I mean somebody
being dragged off
something no-one ever affected to see
Congress calls for hearings because of
all this on customer service what if
anything could come out of that well
it's really hard to say at this point
you know the airline's themselves I
think have begun to recognize especially
since United handled its own situation
so terribly in the first few days we
have to respond to these viral videos
basically as fast as they spread so
United has now said that they're no
longer going to ask the police to take
people off the planes they're going to
pay people up to ten thousand dollars
necessarily they're going to have
they're going to retrain the crew to
sort of deal with these situations
better but at the same time I mean these
incidences are going to continue because
you have a situation where the employees
have to follow the letter of a pretty
draconian law because they don't want to
get fired but sometimes when they follow
the letter of that law someone's going
to hold up a camera on them on their
phone and make them a viral sensation
make them the Nemesis of the week can
airlines do anything to get consumer
confidence back then I suppose give them
more room in the seat give them a better
pitch anything well what's happening
right now is sort of interesting right
because you have more and more amenities
in first and business class right while
at the same time the coach is being
squeezed so a bit of a reverse Robin
Hood effect right I mean literally they
are taking from the lower income space
to give to the higher income yeah and so
you know you could certainly have a
policy where you announce we're no
longer going to do this we're going to
be the sort of plane that's for the
common man but then that puts you in
right in line of the investors who say
wait we want you to make as much money
from possible we want you to squeeze
employees we want you to squeeze
customers we want you to give all these
amenities to business fliers so it's a
really complicated situation that is not
going to have an easy outcome yeah if
you just give me a little more legroom
and a bigger bag of pretzels I'd be a
little happy or just a bag of pretzels
you got very good Derek Thomson thanks
so much for being here this morning